now last week i thought i was done with
rejuvenation but we are back for even
more and i mean that literally for the
video but also for the research paper we
will take a look at where they do more
than once expression of these yamanaka
cellular reprogramming factors
yeah who's up for round two
at different onset times and for varying
extents
in physiologically aging mice
but is it causing rejuvenation and what
do the results say well we'll take a
look in this video
now if this is the first video of mine
that you've ever watched then hello
welcome to the she science show but
maybe you should watch this video or
this one first because i'm pretty much
just going to cut straight to the chase
this time because in this paper they
were evaluating longer term partial
reprogramming in normal mice
imagine i just did that normal in
quotation marks and by partial
reprogramming in this context it means
expressing the reprogramming factors
otherwise known as the yamanaka factors
for a short time period with periods
where they're not expressed
so the cells start to reprogram
but the idea is it doesn't enable them
to completely reverse to a stem cell and
lose their identity
at least that's the idea
so how do they perform partial
reprogramming in the study
well let's take a look at the different
treatment regimens that they did who
have we got
well they tested both long-term and
short-term partial reprogramming
strategies
there were two different long-term
treatment regimens 7 and 10 months
starting at 15 and 12 months of age
and one late onset short-term treatment
so only one month for free programming
starting at 25 months of age
and then how did they do it
well they use genetically modified mice
whereby the yamanaka factors are
expressed
after being treated with doxycycline
which enables the expression of these
genes
and for the partial aspect they give my
stoxycycline for two days and then five
days without it
so it's interesting to note at this
point that this differs from what we
looked at last week where the mice were
given doxycycline for seven days our
base in that paper it was only those
seven days that they did it
okay so different and actually
interestingly the doxycycline levels
that they used also different but
they're different papers done in
different labs and they're not doing the
same thing but they were both interested
in looking at the same outcomes is their
rejuvenation
well in this paper they assessed the
mice and took different tissue samples
after the interventions and looked at
molecular markers such as dna
methylation gene expression changes
metabolomics and histology so what did
they see
well the only intervention that seemed
to show more consistent changes were the
long-term protocols so i'm not really
going to focus on the short-term ones
here
and firstly they looked at dna
methylation a marker that is thought to
track with age
they see in the long-term treatment
regimens a reduction in epigenetic age
in the kidney and liver but it is worth
pointing out that they used a new type
of epigenetic clock the lifespan uber
correlation which i frankly don't know
much about
and that the results using this clock
were better than the traditional methods
so potentially not the most valid data
set
plus there wasn't many mice in this part
of the paper
so maybe there's something going on with
the epigenetics but what about the gene
expression
well in the skin where they saw some
changes in dna methylation they also saw
some changes in gene expression and
sorrow reduction in genes associated
with senescence and inflammation
but gene expression is not a great
indication of senescence so what about
the metabolite changes
well at the end of the 22 months there
were some differences between mice that
did and didn't have partial
reprogramming
one metabolite that stood out for me was
two hydroxy isocopic acids but it wasn't
clear what the trend was with age is it
supposed to be going up or down there
just seemed to be a difference after
this reprogramming
anyway what does this all mean well like
last week there seems to be more of a
mechanistic paper than a functional one
and it seems an important takeaway was
that whatever they were doing to the
mice was well tolerated but without
lifespan data it's hard to say if any of
these changes that we can see with this
partial reprogramming strategies is
actually causing any rejuvenation and
engaging process
and at least from my opinion based on
the strategy that they were doing maybe
this partial reprogramming was maybe a
bit too partial
as there weren't you know many great
changes in the mice
and so these past few weeks now i've
truly gone down a rejuvenation rabbit
hole and i don't think we've escaped yet
because i will definitely be back next
week with another rejuvenation video but
anyway another thing you have to
remember about is that this study was at
a mice
and we are not mice and i guess the
other interesting question is how do we
ever translate these different
genetically modified mice protocols into
human therapeutics
and on that bombshell
i hope you learned something in this
video thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening